bueno yo venía a contaros una historia
la historia es de cómo hacemos el cuerpo
humano transparente y por cuerpo humano
transparente me refiero a no me refiero
a cómo hacerlo invisible sino que quería
trasladaros como la imagen médica nos
permite explorar los confines del
interior del cuerpo humano desde
nuestras células hasta sistemas
biológicos completos pasando por los
tejidos y por los órganos no
pero pero como lo hacemos no vamos a
irnos primero al año
1896 el doctor
morton probablemente en una de las
primeras radiografías del abdomen cuando
tenía que compartir la colega no decidió
por primera vez en la historia escribir
lo que él observaba en las imágenes en
un papel y este es el primer informe
radiológico que conocemos podemos leer
en este informe como decía no hay
piedras de tamaño apreciable en el riñón
pues bien
a radiología la imagen médica ha
evolucionado muchísimo desde 1896 con
resonancia magnética tac que es la
tomografía computarizada rayos-x la
digitalización pero como es a día de hoy
un informe radiológico
bueno hoy en día la sociedad radiología
norteamericana por ejemplo nos
recomienda está plantilla de informe a
los radiólogos para diagnosticar un tag
del abdomen pero algo que nos llama la
atención son expresiones como que no se
aprecian adenopatías en el abdomen no se
aprecian no se observan porque no
simplemente decimos no existen
adenopatías o no existen lesiones en el
abdomen
esta reflexión es la que me motivó para
iniciar toda esta aventura y en realidad
es porque este órgano maravilloso este
órgano bello es limitado
órgano el ojo humano nos permite
detectar 100 tonalidades diferentes un
millón de colores pero en realidad
cuando la enfermedad aparece produce
cambios tan sutiles en los píxeles de
las imágenes que escapan al ojo humano y
tenemos constantemente una carrera una
lucha del ojo humano desnudo del
radiólogo por detectar estos cambios
sutiles versus la enfermedad que lo que
intenta es avanzar e introducir esos
cambios y de ahí sale la necesidad de
cómo podemos objetivar cómo podemos
saber de verdad lo que ocurre en el
interior del cuerpo humano pues tenemos
una necesidad y esa necesidad es nada
más y nada menos que la de medir tenemos
que medir lo que ocurre en el interior
del organismo cómo lo hacemos gracias a
la digitalización las imágenes en
realidad a día de hoy son conjunto de
píxeles y los píxeles representan
intensidades diferentes números valores
que nos permiten extraer propiedades
computacionalmente
propiedades tanto geométricas
características de la anatomía tamaños
formas de las estructuras anatómicas
pero también funcionales qué áreas del
cerebro se activan o qué
función tiene por ejemplo el páncreas
estas son características que se pueden
extraer desde las imágenes médicas una
frase que me ha inspirado siempre es la
de lord kelvin cuando dijo que cuando
puedes medir aquello de lo que estás
hablando y lo expresas en números en
realidad sabes algo de ello así que
siempre imagino en la situación actual
sin números en realidad sabemos mucho
menos qué objetivando toda la
información que podemos extraer cómo
podemos extraer números de las imágenes
médicas cómo podemos realizar esa
objetivación con las biopsias virtuales
las biopsias virtuales no son nada más y
nada menos que medidas que podemos
extraer de las imágenes médicas con
técnicas computacionales y nos explican
cómo está el individuo
yo he dedicado toda mi carrera
profesional a crear biopsias virtuales
para todo el cuerpo humano desde el
sistema nervioso central el cerebro
aparato respiratorio músculo esquelético
salud de la mujer salud del hombre y
estas biopsias virtuales son las que nos
han permitido introducir una nueva
manera de interpretar las imágenes en la
medicina
pero no podemos quedarnos aquí porque
estas biopsias virtuales necesitan
comunicarse e integrarse en la rutina
clínica cómo se comunican en los
resultados de estas biopsias virtuales
bienvenidos al informe radiológico del
futuro
el informe radiológico la interpretación
de la imagen médica es ya mucho más
objetiva estos son ejemplos de informes
estructurados cuantitativos donde con
técnicas de inteligencia artificial
extraemos automáticamente los hallazgos
del interior del cuerpo humano y son
informes que cubren todas las diferentes
áreas anatómicas pero hasta ahora viendo
estos informes me gusta hacer la
conclusión de que en realidad únicamente
hemos cambiado el proceso no teníamos un
informe radiológico cualitativo y lo que
hemos hecho es cambiarlo a un informe
cuantitativo
bien nosotros pensamos que no debemos
quedarnos ahí en realidad estamos ante
una nueva era de la medicina
igual que tuvimos la aparición de la
genómica ahora mismo tenemos la
aparición de la radio mica este análisis
masivo de las características que
podemos extraer de las imágenes en qué
nos beneficia la radio mica os voy a
poner un ejemplo una de las biopsias
virtuales más sencillas que nosotros
realizamos es el cálculo de los
volúmenes del cerebro en el cerebro
tenemos sustancia gris sustancia blanca
líquido cefalorraquídeo en todas las
diferentes regiones pequeñas y diminutas
del cerebro podemos extraer cada uno de
estos volúmenes de los diferentes
tejidos pues bueno en realidad el
análisis paciente a paciente no nos
aporta información del estado de la
población pero podemos extraer nuevo
conocimiento conocimiento que no existía
antes en la medicina y en la salud como
por ejemplo este tipo de información
donde vemos la sustancia gris del
cerebro de pacientes
versus la edad y lo que nos aporta es
que podemos saber que perdemos por
ejemplo 25 mililitros de sustancia gris
al año cada año que pasa a nuestras
vidas tenemos una pérdida de esa
sustancia gris esto nos permite también
saber que pacientes que tienen 55 años
de edad cronológica en realidad pueden
tener una edad cerebral de 70 como vemos
aquí en este gráfico no podemos utilizar
este conocimiento para detectar de
manera precoz enfermedades
neurodegenerativas como el alzheimer por
ejemplo por lo tanto avanzamos hacia el
conocimiento de la salud poblacional en
este caso cómo está nuestro cerebro por
dentro pero de nuevo
decíamos bien con este conocimiento que
podemos construir más allá podemos
caracterizar el cerebro pero podemos
caracterizar la edad de todos nuestros
órganos quizá podemos tener una edad de
nuestro interior
y cuál es el siguiente paso si queremos
crear esto nosotros pensamos que la
imagen médica es la llave para la
creación de lo que conocemos como los
gemelos digitales son modelos que
representan fielmente a nuestro interior
y estos gemelos digitales no son más que
avatares de nosotros mismos un avatar
que se puede crear cuando nacemos que se
puede ir popular con información desde
el análisis de sangre
dna where balls todos los dispositivos
que llevamos y por supuesto la imagen
médica que es lo que nos permite
visualizar nuestro interior
estas técnicas distribuidas a lo largo
de toda nuestra vida no utilizando por
ejemplo radiación ionizante como el tak
cuando somos pequeños sino en edades
donde el beneficio supera al riesgo con
esta distribución lo que nos permite es
caracterizar el estado de salud de todos
los individuos y aquí pensaremos bueno
pero estamos proponiendo entonces crear
programas de cribado para toda la
población
esto sería muy caro no es lo que el
cerebro nos induce siempre a pensar al
principio bueno nosotros decidimos
probarlo y este es un ejemplo de uno de
los proyectos que hemos hecho es el
proyecto inma genoma este es el doctor
josep puig es un radiólogo del clínic de
barcelona que colabora con nosotros
en este proyecto
pusimos una resonancia magnética en un
camión un equipo de ecografía también en
un camión y se adquirieron a dos mil
voluntarios sanos de más de 50 años de
la zona de girona y pueblos de alrededor
bueno nuestras sorpresas fue que un 10%
de estos voluntarios sanos tenían
obstrucción de la carótida y fueron
derivados al hospital de referencia para
colocar un stent para poder prevenir un
posible ictus que podría aparecer mañana
en un año o en cinco años y lo que
tenemos muy medido y muy claro es que
las pruebas de imagen son económicamente
mucho más ventajosas que una
intervención de urgencia cuando tenemos
un ictus paralizando la vida de una
persona y paralizando la vida de toda
una familia por ejemplo
y para terminar quería compartir este
ejemplo quizá más ambicioso todavía en
el que se nos ocurrió a poder liderar un
consorcio europeo de investigación en
gemelos digitales en pacientes de cáncer
pediátrico
y en este caso lo que nos propusimos fue
crear esos gemelos digitales de los
pacientes y de sus lesiones no con el
objetivo de conocer el estado de salud
sino con un objetivo mucho más ambicioso
como es el de poder evaluar la
efectividad de los tratamientos la
efectividad de los fármacos no en el
paciente en sí sino en el modelo digital
del paciente en su gemelo digital de
manera simulada y ahora por primera vez
en la historia hemos conseguido ya
simular el comportamiento de los tumores
con diferentes agentes quimioterápicos
antes de que se implanten o antes de que
se administren al paciente y este es un
ejemplo de esa aplicación desde la
objetivación de la imagen médica hasta
la simulación
en el gemelo digital así que para
concluir me gustaría recapitular
diciendo que no solo queremos implantar
las biopsias virtuales para cambiar ese
proceso sanitario en medicina
queremos conocer cómo es el interior del
cuerpo humano queremos conocer el estado
de salud la edad de todos nuestros
órganos y finalmente conseguir hacer el
cuerpo humano transparente a lo largo de
todo el ciclo de vida de los individuos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]